- This video was sponsored by Skillshare,
which is a place where you
can learn basically anything
you want for less than $10 a month.
Anyway, let's get to it.
(papers rustle)
Russia here we go.
It's like this page and
this page, this is Russia.
It's huge.
It doesn't even fit on one of these pages.
I ripped the page.
Let's look at Russia
(upbeat music)
(guns bangs)
But wait.
Yes this is Russia, but
Russia is also this and this
and this,
this one country encompasses
over a 100 languages
spread across 11 times zones.
I mean the place is freaking huge.
Countries aren't really
supposed to be this big.
So how did this happen?
How did Russia become so damn big.
Countries come in all shapes and sizes.
You have really small
countries like here in Europe
the country of Monaco is tiny.
It's literally two square kilometers
like smaller than most cities.
Now that's obviously an outlier.
So let's look at a more average
size country like Belgium.
More like 11,000 square kilometers.
Then you have even bigger
countries like France
that like 550,000 square kilometers.
Over here in the United States,
where everything is apparently bigger.
You have States that
are bigger than France.
Like the state of Texas is
695,000 square kilometers.
All 48 of these continental
United States are huge
by European standards at least.
This whole continental United States
is 8 million square kilometers.
So you have all these
different sizes of countries.
The average sort of looks like this
and then you have the second
largest country on earth
which is Canada huge.
But now take a look at the size
of the largest country on earth.
Russia is huge.
It is more than double the size
of the continental United States.
17 million square kilometers.
Makes up one eighth of the
total habitable area on earth.
And it's almost double
the next biggest country
on this list, I mean it's mindblowing.
Russia is a part of Europe.
It also shares a beach line with Turkey
but then you go all the way over here
and it has an extensive border
with China and North Korea.
Keep going and it stretches
all the way up here
to where you could literally swim
from Russia to the United
States assuming you can swim,
like two and a half miles.
So yeah, Russia is (beep)
getting huge, it's giant.
But not that long ago Russia wasn't huge.
In fact, relative to
empires and their borders
Russia was kind of a small fish.
That's the story I wanna tell you.
(upbeat music)
A thousand years ago
Russia looked like this,
a loose group of Slavic peoples who were
a growing and prosperous
society here in Eastern Europe
but they had a pretty big weakness.
And that weakness looked like this.
These are flat grasslands,
which are very easy to cross
if you're an army looking to pillage land.
And that's exactly what a group
of horse-riding warriors did.
These guys were the Mongols and
they basically use this path
of flat grasslands
to traverse across Asia
and expand their empire.
40,000 of these Mongo guys on
horses with bows and arrows
eventually made it all the way here
to the Slavic peoples of Russia.
Here's an image of them
invading the cities
and burning them down
conquering these people.
Look how scared these people look.
I mean, I would be too if
40,000 Mongols on horseback
rode into my city.
(speaks foreign language)
(men chant)
Anyway so the Mongols takeover,
this little block of Slavic people
and it really weakens their society.
It breaks up all the cities
that were sort of collaborating
with each other.
And now they're paying
taxes to the Mongols
like this empire that
was from super far away,
like on the other side of the world.
But there was one city
in this area that was
particularly ready to fight back.
They were quietly getting more powerful.
This city was called Muscovy
or Moscow eventually.
And it became the regional
epicenter for trading fur
which is a thing that
was becoming all the rage
in Europe.
Moscow was also learning
how to use gunpowder
and guns and technology
from Europe and before long,
they were able to punch
back against the Mongols
whose big empire was getting
really big and hard to maintain.
And it sort of starting to
crack and Moscow was there
to take advantage of this.
I mean, let's be honest.
There's only so long
you can keep an empire
that looks like this together way too big.
I mean, this is the biggest
land empire in history,
but it didn't last long,
even though they had these bad-ass
warriors on a horseback anyway.
So yeah, Moscow started punching back.
They had fur money and they had gunpowder
and they were having success
pushing the Mongols out
and moving east.
One thing's for sure said Moscow
which was soon becoming
the Russian empire.
"We're not gonna to let
anyone sneak up on us again
"like the Mongols did."
And everyone over here sort of chuckled
in European and said don't you realize
that the only way to keep people out
is to have like mountains
and water to protect you.
And the Russians were like,
oh yeah you mean like these
and the Europeans were like, nice.
So Moscow, which was just a city
but now becoming the Russian
empire starts expanding
towards these mountains
and soon they have like a nice
empire sized set of borders.
Some mountains for protection
have an economy of fur
they have technology and commerce.
They're getting rich things
were looking good for Russia
but wait a minute, can we
overlay that green layer
on the map that shows the
super highway of grasslands
that the Mongols use to invade?
Yeah that one, that one.
(indistinct) look, there's
a flaw in the plan.
Nice try Russia.
But you see that this natural border,
which is great has a huge gap
of flat grasslands that
people can easily pass
directly on their way to Moscow.
So it's the middle of the 15 hundreds.
Moscow has beat back the
Mongols, is expanding east.
They're doing their fur thing.
They find kind of a natural border,
but it doesn't really work.
So they're still looking for
a natural border or water
or something to buffer
their country to the east.
And then this terrible
guy comes into power.
His name was literally Ivan the terrible.
And he had some pretty big
ambitions for expanding Russia.
He's like dude, we don't need
to stop at these mountains.
Let's see how far we
can push this thing east
way past the mountains.
What he finds on the other
side of these mountains
is a very sparsely populated
land of ice called Siberia.
There wasn't a lot of people here
and the people that were
there weren't super resistant
to this Russian takeover.
The main thing that the
Russians had to fight against
was the cold.
But with cold comes furry animals
who have thick coats of fur
which again was incredibly
valuable in European markets.
And that helped fuel this race
to just keep going east.
(upbeat music)
Is it just me or are they
sort of overcompensating?
Like yeah, we get it You
got invaded by the Mongols.
And like, you wanna like make
sure it doesn't happen again,
but like settled down
they just kept moving east
till eventually they
reached the Pacific ocean
the edge of the world.
But they didn't stop there
they just kept going.
I mean, listen, this is so far away
from the original
starting point of Moscow.
And it started to get to the point
where the government back in Moscow
was sort of sending out expeditions
not really sure what they were doing
and what they were taking over
because they couldn't really
like stay in touch with them.
They were just sort of hoping for the best
after one Russian dude
went out on an expedition
and conquered some remote
city in the far east
the government official
back in Moscow said,
nobody really knows why he
did that and to what end.
There is, however, something erotic
taking place in the borders of our empire
Erotic I guess that's
one way to talk about it.
But here's the most interesting part to me
about this Russian imperialism
that is very different
than most imperialism
that I've looked into.
When the Russians would find a tribe
or a people or a culture that
was very different than theirs
because they were so far from home.
They first tried to negotiate with them
and convince them to
join the Russian empire.
If people resisted
it got very predictable
imperialism very quickly
but a lot of tribes didn't resist
and they found it beneficial to be a part
of this growing empire.
So this empire grew
without a lot of conflict
and in the process in
developing a lot of cultures
that sort of kept their
identity their language,
their culture far, far away from Moscow
because of this Russia today
is yes, this huge land mass
but perhaps a better way
to look at it is this.
(upbeat music)
Russia today is divided
into 85 territories.
22 of these territories are
actually called republics
have their own official
language, their own legislature
and basically are totally
independent from Russia
except for in international affairs.
It's like 22 countries within a country
all with their own unique style.
So yeah, well Russia is this.
There's also other versions of Russia.
And I wanna show you some of those.
Stop one let's look at
the Republic of Sakha.
It's located way in
the east and it's huge.
3.1 million square kilometers massive.
This place is in a time zone
six hours ahead of Moscow.
The people here don't
look like Putin at all.
Their ancestors are not from
the original Moscow Russia area
and they speak their own
Northern Siberian Turkic language
as well.
The capital of this Russian
Republic is way up here.
It's called Yakutsk.
It's the coldest large city on earth
with an average temperature
of minus eight degrees centigrade.
And this whole region is
full of these giant holes.
In these holes they're
looking for diamonds,
25% of the world's diamonds
are mined in this Republic.
So yeah, this is Russia.
Next stop down here is Dagestan
which borders the countries
of Azerbaijan and Georgia.
The climate here is so
different than what I think of
when I think of Russia, it is hot and dry
and people here speak 13
different official languages
besides Russian
plus there's a bunch of
unofficial languages.
And 83% of the people
here identify as Muslim,
which again like I don't
think of Muslims in Russia,
but this is Russia.
It's right next to Chechnya
which is another part of Russia,
which is politically and culturally
very much doing its own thing.
The people here declared
independence in the nineties
which caused rebel groups to
militarize and there was war
and terrorist attacks and people died
and Putin may or may not
have planned a bombing
to frame Chechnyan terrorists
to then go to war with them
so he could get approval ratings.
So he could take over the country.
Becoming (indistinct).
No, no, wait, no
I'm not going down the
freaking rabbit hole.
I'm doing one of those
fun geography videos
where we talk about cultural
diversity and like borders
and history and not this stuff come on.
Just is once
can I just go into a video
without having to talk about
the fact that some people
are really terrible?
(sighs)
Anyway so Dagestan down here
has all these different
languages and people
so different than what I think
about when I think of Russia.
Plus, I mean, look at
this fashion culture.
Okay so there's a Republic
here, right on these mountains,
these mountains that we talked about
that were sort of a good natural border
but had a big hole in
them, the Ural mountains
this is the Komi Republic.
The main thing about this Republic is
it doesn't look like the sort of
ice swept Moscow streets
that I'm used to Russia.
This place is known for its natural beauty
beautiful landscapes and
where the gulags where@
the brutal Russian prisons
during the Soviet times
where they would do terrible things.
Anyway, there's these
beautiful rock formations
that are super unique and
people aren't supposed to climb on them
because there's some
legend that it's bad luck,
but of course, foreigners
show up and do stupid things
and they couldn't resist
and here they are.
Anyway, this is Russia.
Okay a couple more, you have
this Republic of come Kalmykia.
You just need to look at this place
and its people to know that
this feels very different
than what you think of as Russia.
And yet this is Russia.
Mother Russia has been sort
of brutal to these people
over the years trying
to erase their culture,
but even still, they persist.
Last one I wanna talk
about is called Tuva.
It's down here.
Here's Putin visiting Tuva a while back.
This is another place where
Russian ethnicity and language
is a minority.
The people here are more
related to the Mongols
and they speak a Turkic
language called Tuvan
which sounds like this.
(speaks in foreign language)
(soft music)
So yeah, the upshot here
is that this is Russia
but so is this and this and this and this.
Russia got really big as they
were searching for a border
and for fur and they just
kept expanding their empire
enveloping all of the people
and cultures that came with it.
Okay let me just be clear about something.
Russia is giant this video
is not 15 hours long.
And so I was able to give
a very brief overview
of the history.
The history is so much more
mind bendingly complicated.
It's like Game of Thrones on steroids
not to mention today's Russia
is also so much more diverse
like a mosaic of cultures and languages
that I was able to give
a little overview for.
But I know that a lot of
you watching are thinking
why isn't he mentioning,
fill in the blank.
I wanna hear from you.
Like, what are the parts of
Russia that you know about
that I didn't mention here
that are the most interesting
or the most surprising
that are more different
from the Russia that we sort of think of?
Let me know in the comments.
I got fascinated with Russia
as we did the Navalny video
a while back
and I'm now becoming deeper
and deeper into this place
and where it came from and
what it looks like today.
I've never visited and I want
to, so maybe I can't though
because I did that the Navalny video
and there'll be angry at
me if I go there anyway,
hadn't thought about that.
(soft music)
Okay before you go, I want to
tell you how you can sign up
for Skillshare for free
and start learning stuff.
Skillshare is this giant
repository of tutorials.
Video-based quality tutorials
that can teach you anything
from photography to business skills
to cooking, to animation.
Like I've learned so many of my skills
from watching web based tutorials,
just like this including a
lot of stuff on Skillshare.
They're really good practical courses.
And I am a major believer
in what they're doing.
I'm also a major believer
that you can acquire
so many skills on your own
outside of a formal environment.
I was using Skillshare long
before they came to sponsor
a video on my channel
because I believe in this.
So there's a link in my description.
And the first 1000 of my
subscribers to click that link
will get a free trial of
this premium membership
so that you can start
learning something today.
It's a sweet deal and you should
totally go click the link.
And go take a course.
There's an awesome
course on graphic design
that teaches you the
fundamentals of Illustrator,
which is a program we
used a lot for this video.
A lot of people don't know that animation
starts with good graphic design.
Learning Illustrator is
a great first step in
learning how to tell stories
visually and to animate stuff.
This course is super well done.
And I definitely recommend it.
Go check out Skillshare.
Thank you all for being here and watching.
Thanks to my patrons for like
being such great supporters
and lots more videos to come soon.
So I'll see you all in the next one.
Bye bye.
(upbeat music)